there is no let-up in this latest phase
of violence
the Gaza Strip battered by Israeli
airstrikes retaliation for the huge
barrage of rocket fire that has been
loosed on civilians across southern
Israel in major city as the sound of
sirens is a constant refrain as we
filmed at a house that had been hit by a
rocket ended up running for cover
sirens could just sound again we're in
Ashkelon without five kilowatts into the
Gaza Strip in here now the Iron Dome is
shooting rockets out of the sky but this
has been going on like this all day the
rockets and mortars that Hamas and other
Palestinian groups are firing are not
always intercepted this strike killed a
58 year old man in the early hours
peppering the building with shrapnel
Palestinians have also been burying
their dead this the funeral of a
pregnant woman and her infant niece but
Israel has denied it was responsible
saying they were killed by accidental
militant fire
Israel claims it strikes are only
hitting military targets but the owner
of this building cannot understand why
it was leveled by an Israeli bomb
I'm really surprised all the people who
are renting a businessman with business
offices and the residents who live here
are very poor they hardly pay any rent
every month had begged them to pay the
rent
I'm surprised and there is no reason at
all to target the building the IDF has
also carried out targeted strikes on
Hamas operatives this car was being
driven by a man Israel claims was
responsible for funneling Iranian money
to armed factions in Gaza sources within
the Israeli security establishment blame
into Palestinian factional rivalry for
the flare-up it seems as if the
Palestinian Islamic Jihad are trying to
drag everybody
Hamas themselves the Gaza Strip and
Israel into some kind of escalation
we have signaled very clearly to Hamas
that we hold them responsible for every
act of violence that comes from the Gaza
Strip towards Israel and we will
retaliate against them Hamas no claims
it is Israel's failure to deliver on
conditions of the previous ceasefire
that have led to the breakdown it is
hard to read where this goes next but
with Israel due to host the Eurovision
Song Contest in the next 10 days the
stakes could not be higher the Egyptians
and the United Nations are trying to
broker another ceasefire to end this
round of violence
but for now the fighting goes on and the
suffering on both sides continues Alex
Rossy Sky News Ashkelon in southern
Israel